-Our next guest
is an Emmy-nominated comedian
who you know from his work
on "Saturday Night Live,"
which is all-new this week,
with host Paul Rudd
and musical guest Charli XCX.
Please welcome Bowen Yang!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
That's what I'm talk--
Oh, come on, now!
Bowen!
-Hi!
-Thank you for coming on.
Last time you were here,
we were talking about
how you played the iceberg
that sank the Titanic.
And it was a giant hit,
and it was so funny.
And since then, you got
nominated for an Emmy for that.
[ Laughter ]
-Thanks.
Thanks, everybody.
-How did it go?
How was the Emmys?
Was it all
like you thought it would be?
-Yeah.
It was everything I dreamed of,
because it took place in a tent
on top of a parking garage
in Los Angeles.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-And I feel like that's
the Emmy experience, baby.
No, it was so fun.
I got to hug Jean Smart.
I got to give her an award,
technically.
And then, I got to, like,
eat little prosciutto things
next to Lorne Michaels
and joke with him all night,
so it was lovely.
-I like seeing you
and talking to you
about the things
that you experience.
'Cause I know you got excited
that Taylor Swift
was on the show.
Musical guest
on "Saturday Night Live"
a few weeks ago, and you're
a big Taylor swift fan.
-Big Swiftie.
-I know you're a big Swiftie.
And did you get to meet her,
and were you nervous?
And walk me through the process.
-I got to meet her
at promos on Thursday.
When you're shooting promos
for the episode,
you do that on Thursday.
People at "SNL" threw me a bone,
said that,
"You can stand next to her."
It was a huge deal.
I got to tell her that
in an improvised line in a promo
that her song "Treacherous"
is the sound of falling in love,
which I believe to be true.
And then, I stood outside
of her dressing room
after the show on Saturday...
-Now we're talking.
Now we're talking.
Yeah.
-Yeah, okay.
This is the meat of it, okay?
I was not sure whether or not
to knock on her door.
Because, it's a real, like...
You know, sometimes you don't --
Sometimes they say, like,
"Don't meet your heroes."
She's a hero.
And she was lovely all week.
But I was like,
you know, after the show,
she's probably riding high.
She doesn't want to talk to,
like, the riffraff like me.
And so,
I finally knocked on her door.
She couldn't have been nicer.
And I said,
"I don't normally do this,
but can we please
take a picture?"
And then, she was like,
"Of course!
Can Sadie Sink,
the star and the muse
of my music video, be in it?"
I was like, "Of course!"
-I love Sadie Sink.
-So we took this photo.
-I want to show the photo.
Here's you,
Taylor, and Sadie Sink.
Look at this.
Is that a perfect photo?
Now look at that.
[ Applause ]
-Pure bliss.
I'm blissed out.
Then, there's more.
So, other people
in the dressing room were there,
and she was like,
"Who should take this?"
And then, Deadpool himself,
Ryan Reynolds was like,
"I'll do it."
That's him.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The star of "Just Friends"
himself, yes.
-How fun is that?
I want to --
This is the holiday show
coming up right now on "SNL."
Will you do anything
over the break?
Are you gonna
get to see your family?
-Yeah. I'm just gonna
hang with my parents
and, like, teach my mom
how to use Netflix
for the eighth year in a row,
so I can't wait.
-You posted some photos
of a hike.
They're from --
Is it Denver?
Where are they from?
Colorado?
-Denver.
Suburban Denver.
-They were going on a hike,
or hiking,
and you took photos
of your parents hiking.
And fans of yours on Twitter
seemed a little confused
that these
are their hiking outfits.
They look line they're going
to a dinner somewhere.
[ Laughter ]
Pretty glamorous.
-They're wearing, like,
steakhouse attire, basically.
-Yeah, they are.
-They look --
They look, like, dressed up.
You know?
-Your dad's wearing loafers,
yeah.
-Loafers.
My dad's wearing loafers
and a button-down
and, like, a sweater vest.
My mom was wearing, like,
a Rhinestone/Swarovski crystal
sweatshirt that she bought
at Goodwill.
[ Laughter ]
And a lot of people
had a lot to say about
what they were wearing.
And I just had to be like,
"Y'all, this is
what immigrants do.
They don't dress appropriately
for things,
and that's fine, and we should
let them do that."
Like, this is not actually
a steakhouse,
and there is no dress code
for this,
and I'm not gonna be
the person to tell them about
Dick's Sporting Goods or Ariano.
-Why can't you be the person
that tells them that?
-I don't want to ruin
their innocence, you know?
I feel like the roles
have switched, and I don't want
to, like -- I want to, like,
keep them the way they are.
-Yeah, exactly.
I want to congratulate you
on your podcast, by the way.
"Las Culturistas"?
Am I saying it correctly?
-Nailed it.
-Thank you.
-Nailed.
-You got named one of
the best comedy podcasts of 2021
by Vulture.
Congrats on that, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Yeah, it's a real honor.
-This weekend, Paul Rudd
on "Saturday Night Live."
-Paul Rudd, yeah.
-I mean he's the best.
What can we expect?
Anything --
Can you give us any hints?
-I think you're gonna see
Mr. Rudd just be
Sexiest Man Aliving
all over the place.
And I think that'll be great.
I think it's his fifth time
hosting, so that's kind of cool.
-Oh, maybe a Five Timers?
Maybe a five --
-Maybe a Five Timers moment.
I don't know.
-All right.
-I can't say much more
than that.
-There you go.
I love you.
Bowen yang.
Thank you for the scoop.
Check out "Saturday Night Live"
this weekend
with host Paul Rudd,
musical guest Charli XCX.